à tous ceux qui entendent ce message est
diffusé depuis la base militaire
d'urgence à et rock
je vous rappelle qu'on est en guerre une
seule erreur peut gâcher tout notre
travail
vous croyez tout ça ces promesses de
produire un nouveau vaccin crois moi
quand je te dis qu'elle se moque de fond
team tech clamant c'est quoi ce truc
pourquoi l'avoir épargnée j'ai besoin de
lui pour mes recherches quelque chose en
lui et avec eux la transformation
j'aimerais que tu me dises que c'est qui
est cette chose pour toi ça pourrait
être la découverte qu'il nous fallait
je sais que je peux arrêter le virus
mais tu as vaccin avec toi c'est bien ce
que je pensais ni complètement salut je
suis le seul à voir ce qui se passe tu
sais ce que ça me saoule blessés cette
chose rester ici le jeu en vaut la
chandelle
une seule erreur peut cacher tout notre
travail
il a réussi à se libérer
on a besoin de lui en vie c'est trop
tard elle peut rien faire j'ai besoin
que tu me dises que tu peux vraiment
triste encore les morts ont pu entrer à
cause des conneries tout arrêter ça
manque l'homicide a faut-il est mort
je sais que je peux arrêter le virus ça
va mal